Tình như tình như tạp t bên dưới Thai Lan, các buại chia sẻ giám sát của bực,
nhằm theo sói tình hình báo hỗ trợ kìm sát của hoang.
Tổng tư lệng các lượng buồn trang mà là dìa, đại tướng Tân Sree, Mốt, Nhi Trâm,
Jafar, sẽ dân đầu nhóm quan sát an siang giám sát tại thứ liệu.
Còn với sự chựa giúp từ vệ tình giám sát giòn Mỹ cùng cấp, theo kế hoạch.
Các trong tiên tuy thập được sẽ tổng hợp và báo cáo tại một nghiệp bộ trường ngoại sóa siang.
Qua đỏ cùng cấp đến sát phát quan về sĩnh biến anh nền lập trường của các biến quan vàng huy còi anh hưởng tưu địa khu bực.
Đây được sẽ là bức đi nhằm tăng cường vài cho chúng tâm của ASEAN trong sửi cái điểm ngọng nội khối.
Chúnga kìa đỏ thái lan đã bởn sọng lạnh dưới nghiệm tầm một số khu bực biến dưới.
Đồng thời tăng cường trên khai lực lượng đặc nghiệp bộ sôn nhằm bảo đảm anh nền.
Các buổi chia của ASEAN có biển pháp kiểm soia biến dưới bao gồm định đón cửa cơ cơ hủ hổ sống phần.